another thing i think you're working on
is the hitman tv series
yeah right so as i said you landed on
your feet
um talk a little bit about where that's
at because
hitman is one of those things where i
think is much honestly
i think it's better suited for a tv
series than a movie
i think that an eight or ten episode
hitman series
could be really cool um yeah and uh you
know i was hired to uh
i wrote episode one and two and what was
great is they let me
um kind of come in with how you
introduce a character like that
to our post-modern world right and
i did it very much like uh you know
third man meets
uh three days the condor you know oh two
threes in there that's cool
um and you're introduced to a guy who's
very much
you know the hitman we know from the
games but he's got a full head of hair
and he's an independent he has a handler
he's got a life
he's very much kind of like that early
80s late 70s assassin we read about in
the books right
but at a certain point he gets he gets
he gets a gig
and that gig unveils the reality that no
choice he's ever
made has been his own and of course you
know the the show ends with him in a
mirror
finding un hidden under his skin the
barcode
right so suddenly it becomes a mystery
of who am i really
um born did that excellently uh this is
more of like
what is true in regards to the people in
my life what has been manufactured what
are thoughts
you know it's the nature versus nurture
of it all and to your point
we get we get into the head of a
character that in the games there's not
much of a character there
but who is this guy really and why do
you root for him
and so we gotta give him a moral compass
and uh
it's glory at the same time like it's a
tough sell because even with the
continental and john wick man
uh so your main character is a hitman in
a tv show why do i give a [ __ ]
and so we have to come in and hard sell
it's a western man
uh who do you root for you root for the
grey hat and he's the ultimate gray hat
it's where um you mentioned you wrote
the first two episodes do you know where
that series is at like what's going on
with it
no i mean it keeps the gestation period
for tv is
forever just like it is for movies and
then some all of a sudden it awakens
um but it's over with fox and uh you
know um
i love everyone over there so we'll see
but you know i
don't know if it's asleep or slumbering
or about to awaken but uh
you know we talk about at least once a
month going can we do something with
that now
got it um so is it one of those things
where you'd be involved more than the
first two episodes
or well here's the thing to your point
i'm like
i got a lot going on because i love to
write and i know a show runner
is what a writer should really want to
be because you get all the money and all
the power
if you want to take it but the reality
is i want to just write
and so on these things like i want to
partner up with a showrunner and
for an analogy for a sport i i don't
necessarily watch
i want to help build the car staff the
pit hand the keens over the driver
and just be there to refuel and take
care of the car you know
i want to do that as much as i can
because the joy is
the writing for me uh being on set is
cool but then about five minutes you're
like eh
you know like i'm best alone in a cave
with the title so well the thing about
being a show runner is that's
your life for possibly up to seven years
one terry metals was a buddy of mine
like he did 12 monkeys and now he's on
picard
and like it's a different beast it's a
completely different beast just like i
i as much as i love comedies i'm not
going to write a comedy i will write an
action comedy i will write something
with
in with humor but comedy man
massive respect for those who do it well
um the same goes for me in a showrunner
a showrunner is
it's uh it's in their dna man they love
getting a call at two o'clock in the
morning that they uh
we got three scenes left to shoot uh the
set's on fire
and the actors become a werewolf and
they're like cool i'll be there in a
second
and me i'm like what show is this